Nothing in the universe is static in the Milky way.
Billions of stars orbit the galactic center.
Some like our sun are pretty consistent keeping a distance of around 30,000
light years from the galactic center,
completing an orbit every 230 million years.
This dance is not an orderly ballet.
More like a skating rink filled with drunk toddlers.
This chaos makes the galaxy dangerous.
Our solar neighborhood is constantly changing with stars,
moving hundreds of kilometers. Every second,
only the vast distances between objects protect us from the dangers out
there, but we might get unlucky in the future.
At some point,
we could encounter a star going supernova or a massive object passing by
and showering earth with asteroids. If something like this were to happen,
we would likely know thousands if not millions of years in advance,
but we still couldn't do much about it.
Unless we move our whole soda system out of the way
To move the solar system. We need a Stella engine,
a mega structure used to stare at a star through the galaxy.
It's the kind of thing that might be built by an advanced civilization with
Dyson's fair level technology.
That's thinking about their future billions of years ahead of time,
but how do we possibly move the hundreds of thousands of objects in the solar
system? The good news is we can ignore all of that.
We only need to move the sun.
All the other stuff is glued to it by gravity and we'll follow it wherever it
decides to go.
There are lots of ideas about what a static engine might look like and how it
would work.
We've picked two grounded in our current understanding of physics that could be
built. In theory,
the simplest kind of stellar engine is the Scutter thruster, a giant mirror.
It works on the same principle as a rocket like rocket fuel.
The photons released us solar radiation carry momentum, not a lot,
but a bit. For example, if an astronauts turned on a flashlight in space,
it would push them backwards. Very, very slowly.
A stellar engine will work a little better than a flashlight because the sun
produces a lot of photons.
The basic idea of the shuttle thruster is to reflect up to half of the solar
radiation to create thrust and slowly push the sun where we wanted to go.
In order for the scuttle thruster to work, it must be kept in the same place,
not orbiting the sun. Although the sun's gravity will try to put it in.
It will be supported by radiation pressure, which props the mirror up.
This means the mirror would have to be very light made of micron thin reflecting
foil from materials like Anna minium alloys,
the mirror shape is important to enveloping the sun in a giant spherical
shell wouldn't work because that would refocus light back to the sun,
heating it up and creating all sorts of unpleasant problems. Instead,
we use a parabola which sends most of the photons around the sun and in the same
direction,
which maximizes thrust to prevent accidentally burning or freezing
earth with too much or too little sunlight. The only safe place to build a Scot,
our Forester is over the sun's poles.
This means we can only move the sun vertically in the plane of the solar system
and one direction in the Milky way, which limits our travel options, a base,
but that is basically it for a civilization capable of building a
Dyson sphere. This is a relatively simple endeavor,
not complicated,
just very hard to build at full cool.
The soda system could probably be moved by about a hundred light years,
over 230 million years. Over a few billion years.
It gives us near complete control over the sun's albeit in the galaxy.
But in the short term,
this might not be fast enough to Dodge a deadly supernova.
That's why we thought we could do better.
So we asked our astrophysicist friends,
if he could design a fastest at an engine for this video,
he did and wrote a paper about his that's been published in a peer review
journal. You can find it in our sources document.
We're going to call our new starter engine, the Kaplan thruster.
It works a lot like a traditional rocket shoot exhaust one way to push yourself
the other.
It's a large space station platform powered by a Dyson sphere that gathers
matter from the sun to power nuclear fusion.
It shoots out a very fast jet of particles that nearly 1% the speed of light
out of the solar system.
A second jet pushes the sun along like a tugboat.
The cap and thruster requires a lot of fuel millions of tons per second.
To gather this fuel,
our thruster uses very large electromagnetic fields to funnel hydrogen and
helium from the solar wind into the engine.
The solar wind alone doesn't provide enough fuel though.
And that's where the Dyson's fare comes in using its power.
Sunlight can be refocused to the surface of the sun, this heat,
small regions to extreme temperatures,
lifting billions of tons of mass off the sun.
This mass can be collected and separated into hydrogen and helium.
The helium is burned explosively in Thermo nuclear fusion reactors,
a jet of radioactive oxygen at a temperature of nearly a billion degrees is
expelled and becomes our primary source of propulsion from our Stella engine
to the engine from just crashing into the sun.
It needs to balance itself to do this.
We accelerate the collected hydrogen with electromagnetic fields using particle
accelerators and shoot a jet back at the sun. This balances,
the thruster and transfers the thrust of our engine.
Back to the sun in as little as a million years,
this engine can move the sun by 50 light years,
more than enough to Dodge a supernova at full throttle.
The soda system can be completely redirected in its galactic obese in
10 million years, but wait, will we use up the sun this way?
Fortunately,
the sun is so massive that even billions of tons of material will barely scratch
the surface. In fact,
this mega structure will actually extend our son's life since lower mass
stars, burn slower,
keeping the soda system inhabitable for many more billions of years
with a cabin for us to,
we could turn the entire solar system into our spaceship. For example,
by orbiting backwards in the galaxy and colonizing hundreds or thousands of
stars as we pass by them,
it may even be possible to escape the galaxy and tiny and expand beyond the
Milky way.
Stella engines are the kind of machines built by civilizations thinking not in
terms of years or decades, but eons.
Since we know that our son will die.
One day a stellar engine could allow the far future descendants of humans to
travel to other stars without ever having to venture into the terrifying
darkness of interstellar space.
Until we build a Stella engine where a drift and subject to the whims of the
galactic seat, we may not like where it leads us.
Maybe our descendants will set sail and become an interstellar
species for millions of years to come.
This was our last video for the year 12,019 of this year in error.
And what a year, it was so much stuff happened to everywhere,
to so many different people,
calendars and holidays adjust imaginary,
but they help us to cut our lives into pieces that our brains can handle.
We're leaving 12,019 behind with a weird mixture of disillusion and hope
the world is screwed up, but we can fix it in a few days.
This year will be over and we'll get to try again.
Thank you for watching our videos and for sticking around for so many years.
See you all in 12,020.